coming back to theaters in a big way you  ready I'm sure that's my blue steel what  not very good well hey zoolander 2 opens  februari 12th and entertainment tonight  is teamed up with samsung's for a super  fan experience at the new york city  movie premiere I'll get this one lucky  winner and a guest had the chance to  attend as you later to red carpet hang  with the Stars and be our special et  superfan correspondent I in all right  here's how you enter the sweepstakes  just head to Samsung promotions com /  slender too and check this out Derek  Zoolander's first vogue cover with coach  Doug Penelope Cruz famed photographer  Annie Leibovitz took the pics and hey  there supermodels Gigi Hadid along with  jourdan dunn and joan smalls